nato boosting its forces on its eastern
flank in europe in the month since
russia's invasion of ukraine the
alliance has already doubled its troops
levels in eastern ukraine in eastern
europe rather about 40 000 troops are
now under its direct command
that force includes battle groups of up
to 1500 soldiers in estonia latvia
lithuania and poland now nato wants to
station units in four additional
countries like hungary slovakia romania
and bulgaria
secretary general jens stoltenberg said
the measures were part of a reset in
response to a new reality
today nato leaders agreed to reset our
returns and defense for the longer term
to face a new security reality we will
have substantially more forces in the
eastern part of the alliance
at higher readiness one month
since the start of russia's invasion of
ukraine
nato's security environment has
fundamentally changed for the long haul
and we are responding with more troops
with more air assets and more maritime
capabilities
it's a new reality it's uh
it's a it's a new normal and nato is
responding for a long term
us president joe biden is in brussels to
meet with european allies in person he
pledged to support those fleeing the
fighting in ukraine and announced new
sanctions on individuals linked to the
russian regime he also said vladimir
putin has underestimated the resolve and
unity of nato today marks one month
since russia
began its carnage in ukraine the brutal
invasion of ukraine
putin was banking on nato being split
my early conversation with him in
december and early january it was clear
to me he didn't think we could sustain
this cohesion nato has never never been
more united than it is today putin is
getting exactly the opposite what he
intended to have as a consequence of
going into ukraine we have to stay fully
totally thoroughly united thank you
our first guest is alexander sub a
former prime minister of finland
currently he's a professor at the
european university institute welcome to
the day now your country is in the
european union but not in nato after
russia's invasion of ukraine for the
first time most finns say they want to
join the alliance is your country
preparing to apply for membership
yeah i guess the right way to put it is
we are not in nato yet yes i predict
that
finland will file an application for
nato membership not in days not in weeks
but within a few months we basically had
a reversal of opinion polls used to be
50
in against 20 in favor now it's 62 in
favor and 16 against so we have a
parliamentary procedure and we are going
to join nato at the end of the day and
joining nato is because you and your
country fear that putin's goals of
empire extend beyond ukraine
yeah i mean i've been
a minority in advocating finnish
membership ever since 1995 but now i
think our population is rightly so being
driven by what i call rational fear so
the thought is that listen if putin can
slaughter his brothers sisters and
cousins in ukraine why wouldn't he do
the same thing
with finland and i think that the
sentiment that we have is that we never
want to be alone again like we were in
the winter war against the soviet union
so therefore the population is in favor
of nato membership
let's talk a little bit about sanctions
we've seen sanctions in finance and
transport in the world of sports even
energy too but there are continuous
calls from inside ukraine particularly
from president zielenski for an oil and
gas embargo how vital would this step be
i think it would be what vital and
obviously we've seen three now four and
coming up to five waves of sanctions the
way in which i see it is that russia
will be utterly isolated by the end of
this that means political economic
financial sport culture and energy
isolation so i foresee first an oil
embargo and then basically step by step
movement away from russian gas i think
that's the only right thing to do do you
think an oil embargo would push vladimir
putin to ben because that would hamper
his economy severely or is he fully on a
legacy defining mission in ukraine right
now
i think it's very much about his legacy
his place in history you know he wants
to see himself next to ivan the terrible
peter the great or stalin and he'll be
doing everything in his power to achieve
that
and i do think that you know going for
oil embargoes and gas embargoes they
will probably hasten the process of
isolating him but will that change his
mind i'm not 100 sure it will but i
still think that we need to be on the
right side of history here you believe
in instilling some kind of embargo but
here in germany the government is
unwilling to block russian energy given
its dependence on moscow berlin says
this war marked a turning point but it
can't turn fast enough for ukraine what
do you hope germany does in this
conflict with regard to this oil embargo
step by step i think uh and you know i
come from a country with 1 340
kilometers of border and the way in
which we set up our energy portfolio was
to make sure that we would not be
dependent on russia that's why we have
nuclear that's why we never did anything
like the energy then so i would say that
go for the oil embargo first and then
because you can get oil from different
kinds of places in the world yeah we're
going to have to pay a higher price and
then start to start weighing yourself
off of the gas in finland actually gas
is only for the industry so we don't do
any housing on that so it's i guess a
bit easier for finn to say than for a
german and i must also say that as a
professor it's easy to analyze this
stuff from the audience it's a bit more
difficult when you're in the middle of
it and taking those decisions
now there are negotiations ongoing
between russia and ukraine right now we
continue to hear talk though of
so-called finlandization of ukraine that
under duress the smaller neighbor is
essentially forced to accept moscow's
influence and pledge neutrality what do
you say to people who suggest this as a
way out of this war
well you know i love germany but there's
one phrase from germany that i don't
love and that's finlandization i think
it was coined by a german professor in
1966. my answer is is absolutely no
solution to anything and you have to
understand that for us finn's
finalization is actually a little bit of
an insult it's a sore point in our
history we had to compromise our
liberties we had to compromise our
democracy we had to compromise our
security so it is absolutely no solution
for ukraine basta your your country
certainly knows about the difficulties
of making such a step and we've heard
president zielinski say that he too is
not willing to compromise now diplomacy
let's talk about that is there space
here to maneuver when putin's demands
are simply unacceptable to ukraine
well to be honest i mean my experience
comes from the war in georgia in 2008
and i was finland's foreign minister at
the time and also chairman of the osce
so i flew into belize with french
foreign minister bernard kushner and we
mastered a ceasefire agreement in in
five days it had six points
but to be honest the stakes were much
lower at the time it was easier for
president medvedev at the time and prime
minister putin to accept that i don't
think there's room a maneuver for a
ceasefire agreement at the moment so
it's the moment when idealism in other
words peace hits reality in other words
war i just don't see where they could
actually get closer and as i said putin
will destroy ukraine that's his aim and
celenski will fight back and at the end
of the day we'll see who is the last man
standing
alexander staub a former prime minister
of finland thank you very much for your
time and your insights
my pleasure
after a month of war russia's invasion
of ukraine has bogged down reportedly
with the ground offensive stalled in
several places the russian military has
been increasingly targeting civilian
infrastructure
and yet despite the huge number of
ukrainian suffering the country's
military has so far been able to keep
russian forces at bay against all odds
flames and smoke billowing from a
russian transport ship in the harbor of
russian occupied bergyansk
lines for humanitarian aid stretching in
front of bombed out apartment blocks in
the heavily struck city of mariupol
a month into russia's war in ukraine
every day is full of images that only
weeks ago were difficult if not
impossible to imagine in modern europe
the sun was shining in kiev and no bombs
were falling for the moment as soldiers
and civilians reflected on a month of
war
ukrainians have united as never before
perhaps
this makes me very happy
and the russians made a big mistake
coming after our country our land
we will bite their throats it's our
homeland
morale is as high as on the first day
and it will remain so until the last day
victory day we remain determined
ukraine has proven its resilience
but sustained bombardment
bodies in the streets
and life in bomb shelters with limited
or no power or heat
are bound to take their toll on
i try to keep calm and only hope that
everything will be over
and all will be fine as it was before
and to see the smiles returned to
people's faces
and our chances to enjoy life returned
to us
a month ago no one knew how long ukraine
could hold out against russia
and yet despite the toll to human life
and infrastructure
and the sheer size of the russian war
machine
the underdog is still standing
our correspondent matthias birlinger is
in kiev and sent us this assessment
we have just returned to kiev we've been
away for a week in the western part of
the country and
the mood has changed slightly here we
see more shops open
for example
hairdressers are open now they used to
be closed
most of the shops are still closed but a
few more businesses are operating you
see more people on the street you see
more traffic so it feels like the city
is making its way back to normalcy in
very small steps it is of course still a
city in an extraordinary situation you
can still hear shelling uh and in
daytime and at night uh from the
outskirts um the ukrainians have driven
the the russians a bit further away from
the city that's at least what we hear
but
the fighting is close enough that you
can hear it even if you are in the city
center however it seems to be like the
trend seems to have shifted a little bit
that's the feeling here on the ground
the russian troops have tried to capture
kiev everybody understands or or
estimates that this that was their top
priority to capture kiev quickly
decapitate the government and it has not
worked moreover um while russian troops
have advanced to these places around
kiev where they are now quite quickly
they haven't almost been unable to make
any gains within uh
three weeks or so and we've also seen
some signs that they are digging
trenches now um that this is moving
towards a war of attrition rather than
an invasion or or an advance and uh
that's obviously something that
um gives people here the hope that um
the russians uh might that ukraine might
be able to to drive the russians out in
the end or to um
to to create a situation terry has said
this before uh where the russians would
understand that they could not achieve
their goal and then in negotiations they
could be convinced to leave the country
that's the hope now it's still not where
we are it's nothing that people expect
to happen in the
next few weeks or so but it's something
that could be a possible outcome in the
longer term there's very careful but
some optimism is here joining us now is
elliott cohen a defense and secular
security expert at the center for
strategic and international studies
welcome to the program as of right now
the western intelligence assessment is
russia's advance has stalled but in
recent days you've said that's not all
that ukraine is actually winning this
war why do you see it that way
so first let me uh stipulate that uh the
ukrainian population is paying a
terrible price and one doesn't want to
minimize their suffering also i'm saying
that they're winning not that they've
won or even necessarily that they will
win although actually i think in the
long run there's a very good chance of
that it's not just that the russians
have stalled although that we should
pause a moment and think about that the
russians had every advantage going into
this war they surrounded ukraine on
three sides they were able to amass
their forces exactly as they wanted they
were able to launch the attacks just
when they wanted we know that they
thought they could overrun that country
in a few days
and if you look at the map they haven't
actually gotten into the heart of the
country they've been stopped in most of
their offenses and indeed in a number of
areas particularly around kiev
the ukrainians have actually gone on the
counter-offensive but but it really goes
much beyond that let's start with
casualties
the current estimates are that the
russians have probably lost between 10
and 15 000
soldiers killed to put that in
perspective the russians took about 15
000 killed during the course of the
entire afghan war in addition to that
standard rule of thumb in estimating
casualties and this is on the low side
for every individual killed you have
several more who are wounded taken
prisoner or uh or disappear
so in other words what that means is if
a total invasion force of something on
the order of 200 000 maybe less there
are probably about 30 000 troops that
have been taken off the battlefield
those are very very heavy casualties
beyond that we say it's not just private
soldiers getting killed we've they've
lost six generals
that's a testimony to a number of things
poor signal communications
discipline using open
cell phones which can be tracked and
monitored but also the fact that senior
officers generals and colonels have to
go on to the front lines to make things
happen
that means that your junior officers
can't make things happen on their own
we've seen tremendous logistical
failures that notorious uh 40-mile
convoy which wasn't really a convoy is
more like a traffic jam northwest of
kiev
that's a result of logistical
incompetence
and there are plenty of other
manifestations of that as well
so i'll give you just one last statistic
it's quite extraordinary the ukrainians
have captured
more russian tanks
and other kinds of vehicles than they
have lost
and they've captured more russian
hardware that has been destroyed
what that indicates to me is that you
have on the other side a military that's
just not very competent and that's borne
out if you if you look at such videos of
combat as we see
the russians just aren't very good
talk to us a little bit about further
about ukraine now the armed forces today
look vastly different than they did
before 2014 before russia annexed crimea
there's been support from the u.s the uk
and canada in terms of training
extensive training how does the military
look today and that fact is able to hold
off the russian attack right now
well it's a very different military and
you know even in 2014 2015 they were
already getting a lot better and they
were in fact able to deny the russians
their maximal objectives in dunbas i
think probably the most important thing
they've gotten out of training is the
western way of war which involves a lot
of initiative for junior officers it
means having capable sergeants
non-commissioned officers which the
russians don't really have um i think
it's also fair to say that the
ukrainians are actually pretty well
equipped
but most important of all they are
utterly motivated they are fighting for
their lives they're fighting for their
freedom they're fighting for their
families they're fighting on their own
turf
whereas the russian soldiers don't know
what they're fighting for in fact many
of them didn't even know that they're
going off to a war so uh between that
and the the kind of weapons supply that
the ukrainians are getting
they've really in many ways done an
extraordinary job of
setting back the russians and in many
cases defeating them
elliott cohen defense and security
expert at csis thank you very much
you're welcome
[Music]
if vladimir putin believed his invasion
of ukraine would result in a quick
victory he severely miscalculated
ukrainians western intelligence believes
1 000 of his soldiers are either being
killed or injured every day and russian
forces are facing difficulties meeting
their initial military goals as as
forces struggle to regain their momentum
they continue to attack areas with
civilians a warning this next report
contains distressing images
an apartment block under fire
[Music]
this is mario poll the ukrainian city
russia has been targeting since the
start of its invasion
[Music]
targets include its citizens
who've paid a heavy price
this distraught mother holds her
sleeping child
her other child was killed in russian
shelling
for those still here there's little left
we have nothing to eat it's awful it's
just awful no light no heat nothing
russian forces have attacked schools
yeah
he freed us from education
and community buildings
when this theater was bombed it was
acting as a shelter for hundreds of
people it's still unclear how many died
hospitals too have been targeted
[Music]
this pregnant woman who was filmed being
rescued from mario paul's maternity
hospital later died
half an hour after her baby was
delivered stillborn
since the war began a month ago there
have been more than 60 attacks on
ukrainian medical facilities including
hospitals
according to the world health
organization
over the last few weeks russian air
power and artillery have struck at
residential areas in other cities like
kharkiv
how could this monster oh my god
monster come up with something like this
to destroy everything people are
starving there is no water no wood for
heating and he decided to destroy a city
in the 21st century a beautiful city
one month on it seems no one not even
children are safe in putin's war
our next guest is kier giles who's a
russia expert at the foreign policy
think tank chatham house thank you for
joining us here we're seeing the bombs
now falling on civilian targets that's
been going on throughout this four-week
war so far there is concern putin will
resort to tactics similar to what he
employed in chechnya how can that war
help us predict what he might do here in
ukraine as he's not necessarily making
the gains on the battleground that he
had hoped for
well concerned that he may resort to
doing this is a strange way to put it
because that is exactly what has been
happening since day five of this war it
wasn't right from the beginning because
let's not forget in the very early
stages russia thought it could win
quickly and easily without even a fight
because they assumed believing their own
propaganda that ukraine was a pushover
and it would be a liberation of the
ukrainian people from this imaginary
fascist band that was governing them but
instead as soon as russia realized it
was not going to be able to win cleverly
and not going to be able to win through
military means they almost immediately
pivoted to this default tactic of
causing the maximum civilian suffering
possible of engineering these
humanitarian disasters because that for
russia is an effective way of winning
wars they've seen how effective it is
not only in chechnya also in syria
because not only does it put pressure on
president zielinski to make concessions
to surrender in order to end the
suffering it also means that other
countries around the world will also be
piling on that pressure trying to get
zielenski to end the war in order to
preserve life so that life can go on
when we talk about a potential off-ramp
for putin this is a big discussion here
in europe what can european allies do to
push him to you know
exit ukraine is there anything that you
see happening here that would push
vladimir putin to turn his troops around
or is he going to continue this way
well the key question is what exactly
vladimir putin thinks is happening and
again wayfi believed his own propaganda
before moving the troops in does he now
have reliable sources of information on
what the real situation on the ground is
he must be aware that the war has not
been won in 48 hours but in terms of the
strength of ukrainian resistance and the
appalling casualties that the russian
troops themselves
appear to be taking while not making
forward progress it's whether that
information is actually getting through
to president putin so he has a real
appreciation of the situation on the
ground that will determine what he
thinks his achievable war aims are now
some of those aims of course have
already fallen away you no longer hear
talk about the the imaginary
de-nazification of ukraine in the
country with a jewish president but
other ones looking for territorial
control looking for the demilitarization
of ukraine are probably still perfectly
reasonable russian aims and something
that president putin could claim he has
achieved even if russia pulls out its
troops now so there are two different
aspects here there's the reality on the
ground and there's what president putin
can actually sell to his domestic
population as a success in this war
now president zielenski has repeatedly
said that this war will not end with
ukraine do you think putin's aspirations
lie beyond ukraine that though you know
ukraine is the crown jewel of the
russian empire in his mind there's more
territory that he rightfully sees as
belonging to russia
well that's exactly right this is not
the war it is a war it is the first war
in russia's program of reconquest and
president putin has laid out very
clearly what he wants to reconquer he's
talking about the decisions of a hundred
years ago when the russian empire was
dissolved as being catastrophic mistakes
and other russian decision makers as
well have come out with this idea that
it is the russian empire that needs to
be restored and that of course includes
not just ukraine not just belarus but
also full-fledged members of the eu and
nato and the western community of
nations that's estonia latvia lithuania
poland finland so yes this is just the
first phase in russia's wars of
reconquest
is there anyone in putin's inner circle
that's providing him with the
information of perhaps what's actually
happening on the ground we clearly
understand that this was not the case
before this invasion but do you think
that anyone within his inner circle
again could sort of change his mind or
is he the one making all the decisions
and he doesn't want to hear it
we have no way of knowing that and
anybody that says confidently that they
do know exactly who is whispering in
putin's ear is either making it up or is
disclosing classified information that
they never should we simply cannot tell
it's a black box uh what exactly is
feeding into putin's decision making all
that we know is that it is producing the
wrong results
talk to us a little bit about the
support within russia for this war we
know about the propaganda we know that
some independent stations television
stations have shut down that newspapers
are not able to even call this a war
what kind of support is there inside
russia for this war
that too is hard to tell because russia
has taken steps not only to isolate its
own population from news and information
from the outside world but also made it
very hard to figure out exactly what
russian people think after all surveys
of opinion conducted from outside the
country are now illegal precisely so
that we cannot tell that kind of
information now anybody that's been
inculcated with a decade plus of russian
war propaganda through state television
you could forgive them for actually
believing everything that they're being
told about this being a crusade to
liberate ukrainians from neo-nazis but
the young people who are accessing
information from outside the country may
have a different view but even so it may
not make any difference russia has also
prepared itself for crushing popular
dissent the repression has been getting
tighter not just since the war began but
over a period of several years and
russia is fully prepared with its
rascavaria its national guard internal
security forces to inflict mass
casualties on protests on the streets in
russia itself
kier giles a senior consulting fellow of
the russia and eurasia program at
chatham house thank you very much
thank you
the world health organization says about
half a million refugees who fled ukraine
will need treatment for mental health
disorders the w.h.o is stressing the
need for immediate support as the
refugee crisis grows with many
struggling as their families are torn
apart
the countries bordering ukraine have
become a haven for millions of people
fleeing the war they arrive in poland
and moldova desperate for safety
natalia escaped the shelling in
mikolayev but left her husband behind
we fled when they started bombing that's
why we decided to leave our home 500
meters away from us there was a rocket
explosion it was very scary that's why
we decided to leave
many families have been separated by the
fighting
i took a risk and fled with my daughter
but our relatives are too scared my
older daughter with her child was too
scared how could she manage he's only
four years old
but it's also scary here we don't know
where to go now
the conflict has created the worst
refugee crisis since the second world
war authorities are doing what they can
to help new arrivals
[Music]
most of the children here are without
their fathers who are required to stay
in ukraine to fight
the world health organization says
arrivals are not only suffering from a
range of physical health problems but
also psychological distress
the need for
psychosocial support because people have
been suffering a lot
children
are displaced from their family
so this is a tremendous
mental health stress number one number
two
or what we call non-communicable
diseases or chronic diseases
people with high blood pressure
with cardiovascular disease
with diabetes
whose treatment has been interrupted
and the third one or the communicable
diseases
first and foremost 19.
several eu states are taking ukrainians
in but while these refugees have reached
physical safety many will need a lot of
support to help heal the mental scars
left by what they've experienced
let's bring ndw correspondent max zander
who is standing by at the polish
ukrainian border max we know that poland
has already taken in more than two
million ukrainian refugees so far how is
the situation unfolding where you are
one month into this war
right so the situation here on the
ground in in poland in the border region
is evolving
pretty much everything that's happening
on the other side of the border in
ukraine
sooner or later will have an effect on
what's going on here right now
but at the moment it seems at various
points here in the region be it the
train station in chiamishla which is the
first point of entry for many ukrainian
refugees uh fleeing by train
or the border crossings or places like
this one right here um
in chemistry in the city uh this seems
the situation has become a lot calmer
over the last couple days and maybe just
to we can give you a little uh
impression of what the situation is
right now this is a former warehouse a
vacant warehouse which now serves as a
registration
for
passengers and for people who
come to ukraine have come from ukraine
to poland and
need to continue on
and
there are ngos on the ground as well
helping out uh serving some food and you
can also get some medical attention here
donations are being handed out collected
uh by volunteers and ngos and uh by the
municipality a lot of uh
groups they're pitching in um
but it seems uh that as you can see that
there's not a lot of traffic here right
now uh this is due to the numbers having
gone down of new arrivals um by
a threefold um so at the moment uh this
is a much needed rest for
for some of the volunteers we spoke to
for some of the infrastructure here on
the ground but everybody knows that the
situation sooner or later could change
could
if the russian military makes
significant gains in ukraine this could
mean that a lot more people could come
and the situation could look very
different very soon max the polish prime
minister has said the european union
needs to crush russia with sanctions
poland has also floated the idea of a
nato peacekeeping force in ukraine is
there a sense that poland is not fully
satisfied with how its allies are
responding to this war
right i mean we heard some very strong
words from the polish government in
particular from the polish prime
minister uh mulavitsky
let's not forget that poland is a
front-line country so to say there's a
war raging on their doorstep
everything that happens in ukraine
in terms of the war is going to be felt
here um people coming from fleeing from
ukraine uh first and foremost come to to
poland um a that's being sent a lot of
it goes through poland so so poland has
very much to do with what is going on
there um but we also have a sense that
there's also some some fear um that uh
poland could face
further consequences in one way or
another um so there's uh yeah um
polish leadership is very much outspoken
and asking for um yeah very very that
for very strong measures um uh against
russia um you said rightly so prime
minister miloveci has asked for a nato
peacekeeping mission this has been
rejected um he's also asking been asking
for stronger and more sanctions for
example the banning of trade on sea and
and land routes with russia entirely um
now how much of this is realistic uh is
not clear but the bottom line is um that
polish government definitely is
concerned dw correspondent max zander at
the polish ukrainian border thanks for
this max